as much as we'd like to focus on
creating and managing threads and work
packets we tend to ignore the biggest
hardest problem in threaded memory my
name is Colt McAnlis and while threading
and memory have a long complicated
history and programming there are some
specific nuances on Android that you
need to be aware of you got to remember
that memory in computing isn't really
thread safe when two threads are
operating on the same block of memory
weird things happen I mean you can get
memory contention problems with
readwrite access order ABA problems rips
in the fabric of space-time ok maybe not
maybe not the last one but anyhow fixing
these means restricting memory access
from threads using locking which is a
whole separate video series that we're
not going to get into right now but most
important to understand is that Android
isn't immune to these problems for the
most part the same techniques you use to
deal with these issues on other
platforms can be applied here too but
there are a few specific cases that you
need to be aware of let's start with the
fact that by design UI objects are not
thread safe UI objects are expected to
be created used and destroyed all on the
UI thread and not guaranteed to behave
properly on any other threads trying to
modify or even reference them on other
threads can throw exceptions cause
silent failures crashes and just general
weirdness that in fact just holding a
direct reference to a UI object on a
worker thread can be a problem for
example your work object may contain a
reference to a view but before your work
completes on the worker thread the view
is removed from the view hierarchy on
the main thread so what do you do here I
mean you can't trust any of the
properties of that view since the data
has changed and updating those
properties doesn't really mean anything
since it's not part of the hierarchy
anymore and won't be drawn to the screen
and this gets crazy really quick I
remember views contain references to
their owning activity I mean we did a
whole video on how leaking those views
can cause all sorts of memory problems
but this gets even worse when threading
is involved if an activity is destroyed
but there still exists a threaded block
of work that references it the activity
won't get collected until that work
finishes so if you kick off some work
and the user rotates the screen three
times in a row before that work
completes you could end up with three
instances of that activity object
resident in memory and to be clear it's
not just explode
references to UI objects that you need
to worry about you also have to be
cautious of implicit references as well
check out this very common scene all the
time coding pattern in Android apps
you've got some threading object that's
declared as an inner class of an
activity the problem here is that the
async task object now has an implicit
reference to the enclosing activity and
will keep that reference until the work
object has been destroyed the result is
the same problem until this work
completes the activity stays around in
memory and by the way this type of
pattern also leads to common types of
crashes seen in Android apps some block
of threading work is kicked off but the
user hits back or does something else to
change the topmost activity later when
the threaded work completes it tries to
make updates to a state that's no longer
valid the result is a dialog box
notifying me that an app I haven't used
for 10 minutes has crashed which is kind
of awkward for everybody the takeaway
here is that you shouldn't hold
references to any types of UI specific
objects in any of your threading
scenarios which leads to the natural
question how are we supposed to update
the UI from threaded work the trick here
is to force the top-level activity or
fragment to be the sole system
responsible for updating the UI objects
for example when you like to kick off
some work create a work record that
pairs a view with some update function
when that block of work is finished it
submits the results back to the activity
using an intent or a run on UI thread
call the activity can then call the
update function with the new information
or if the view isn't there just drop the
work altogether and if the activity that
issued the work was destroyed then the
new activity won't have a reference to
any of this and will just drop the work
to see no crashes no memory leaks just
pure clean fun now if you ever want a
deeper look at how threading and memory
are working together make sure to check
out the powerful new tools inside of
Android studio which just get an awesome
revamp as a version 2.0 the deeper you
go into Android performance the more you
realize how important memory is on this
platform which is why you should check
out the rest of the memory videos on the
Android performance patterns playlist
and don't forget to check out our
Google+ community as well so keep calm
profile your code and always remember
perfmatters